yeah so let's have a think about this I
added up these two wave functions I got
a new wave function bigger amplitude and
there was a phase shift okay and we used
calculus to work that out okay but
that's a bit of an awkward way to do it
this calculus business it was what we
had to do a bit of we had to think quite
hardly like what does this mean was that
mean which way am I going okay so
there's a better way to approach this
okay this is last thing I'm doing them
it should stand up and have a shake
let's go over here we can work with that
right and make some kind of comparison
between the left on the right here
without bringing this differentiation of
business in right what did we learn
before calculus what was the first three
you know topic you did treat expansions
and this sure enough is like as cannon
fodder for treats mentions okay so how
do you expand this thing take that line
sine X plus cos x you might have noticed
by the way I used three lines instead of
two okay because the idea is that these
are equivalent not just equal to each
other okay ya go okay so if that's equal
to 0 sine X myself let's expand this guy
from the right hand side okay are at the
front okay this is our regular sign a
plus B expansion so how does it go cos
alpha okay + coz that's a plus and then
you switch the order right so it's going
to be close x sine alpha okay now it
looks worse but it's better because
we're going to try and do something with
this like we did back in quadratics to
the end of you 10 we did this topic all
my little idea called quadratic
identities right you got a quadratic on
one side quadratic on another and you
had to say they were equal by comparing
their coefficients do you remember this
is it ring any bells you like this is a
blog NW tab I didn't let any
let me show you how it works it's really
easy I've got sines and cosines over
here sorry start again I've got two sine
x over here in coat closet over here I
also sine x over here and cos x over
here alright so all the slide X's on
this side should be equal to the sine X
is on this side right and the cos x is
on this side should be equal to cos x is
on that side yeah ok so to make that a
bit more obvious let's write it like
this sine X plus cos x I'll even put the
one bear just for the sake of it make it
super super obvious ok what I do on the
right hand side here how many sine X is
do I have I've got one on the left on
the right I have aa cos alpha that's how
many lots of sine X i have that's my co
efficient and then how many cos x is do
i have i have our sine alpha lots see it
can you see what I'm doing you might
want to even get some colors out you can
see there's my sine X and there's my
sine X right you get the game person so
here at this point we say by comparison
of coefficients
okay on this side I'm one this I have an
archive alpha R coz alpha equals one
this side I'm going to have another one
and an hour sine alpha equals 1 okay so
I'm gonna call this equation one in
question 2 now this is great because
I've got two unknowns amplitude phase
and I got two equations so how am I
going to solve what would you do that's
true in this case we sort of already
knew that right but in a second i'm
going to show you examples where these
numbers are going to be different right
so let me show you a more general
approach which will work a little better
for you i'm going to take advantage of
the Pythagorean de genève right when you
square cos n square sine you put them
together you should get one right so I'm
going to do this one squared plus 2
squared okay so what am I going to get
on the left hand side r squared
that was random monarchy going over here
let inside factor out your R squared and
what you're left with is closed square
plus sine squared which is one so I'm
just not even going to write it over
here I've got two so r is equal to now
pause for a second I'm gonna ask where
is equal to right so I'm about to take
square root ordinarily we would tape
possible my toes right and then you get
rid of one solution I am just going to
take one solution I'm just going to take
the positive one why for now write down
this I want you to keep it in your head
for a minute okay I'm not sure if we get
the time today why they answer at the
end of this lesson or tomorrow okay I
want you to think about why is that the
case okay now this is really good
because it's what we concluded earlier
about the amplitude so thick okay so
I've worked out one unknown I got to
work out the other one namely alpha can
you see how it's going to come out let's
go back to equation 1 okay which said
I'll cause our 4 equals 1 so root 2 cos
alpha equals 1 so that's one on route 2
and sure enough your first angle that
satisfies that is PI over 4 so therefore
i can take my are and i can take my
alpha which I've solved here in here
okay and I can put them up back into
here and say sine X plus cos x is
equivalent to write it so I can use as a
substitute to solve it root 2 sine X
plus
now this is called auxiliary angle
auxiliary just kind of means secondary
on the side sometimes you hear it get
cold I think it's and serene Eagle is
the same idea it's referring to this
video the payment for right that they
believe you're going to have to change
the episode but you got to nudge it over
a little bit right so that's where this
topic gets his name from okay now if you
if your cogs have been turning right and
you've been seeing the kind of question
we've been looking at you can see that
we can use these results auxiliary angle
in much the same way as we can use T
results right to solve the same kind of
equation right because you know 20
minutes ago I showed you this equation
right and you can solve that materials
we started off doing okay well I can
also solve this with this result right
because I can say this business over
here is equal to this right so now what
I do okay divided three
okay dude the thing with the thing you
know the thing right leg it the thing
where you make that X plus the eye on
the hoy was the result yeah the most
articulate answer ever okay now you want
to know what exact angle will give you
sign of that will you want to retreat
what answers are those okay for its
another one ah ok now pause for a second
this isn't the the clearer you are
noticing we've got a similar problem
here then we have a tea result namely to
go from here to here I change the domain
you see that before we change a 20 X on
to write so that meant it wasn't 0 to PI
anymore it was 0 to PI so being that
I've changed this to an end as well you
know suppose I was solving this lot of 2
pi which is pretty normal now that i've
added plan for this domain is different
as well so upset see how i've added the
SR is a yes
okay so can you see when you're dealing
with these problems okay before you were
like oh I'm so confused by domain well
you're going to get by domain you've got
it you've got a sort out to me because
to solve it adequately both methods that
we can use to results more easily angle
are going to adjust the domains somehow
ok now we didn't quite finish we notice
this domain was different so now when we
come over to our solutions right you've
got this and then you've got one more
answer on the end namely siren you a
space nine pound for how all this done
first i lock my solution for X not for
xmas plan for so you take pun for off
everything right which gives you zero
that should be PI on to and that's
what's your plan which are the same
three answers i told you about 15
minutes ago for this question